en fin d'après midi mardi un orage de
grêle s'abat sur la bisbal dame ford a
en quelques minutes les éléments se
déchaînent
cet habitant filmé la scène de
l'intérieur de sa voiture
ces boules de glace qui tombe du ciel
mesure jusqu'à 10 ou 15 cm de diamètre
plus gros qu'une balle de tennis effrayé
tous tentent de se mettre à l'abri au
plus vite comme à l'intérieur de ce
restaurant ce n'est pas normal les gars
ce n'est pas normal pas normal le ciel
est en train de nous tomber sur la tête
cet agriculteur et lui obligé de se
réfugier sous son tracteur
deux de nos campagnes
de la montagne de la vie bat du monde
animal
mais c'est quoi
depuis le 30 juin à nice et c'est un
record la température n'est pas
descendue en dessous des 20 degrés
pendant soixante et une nuits c'est ce
que les météorologues appellent les
nuits tropicales un phénomène il y à la
masse d'air chaude qui a stagné sur la
france mais aussi à un environnement
particulier dans le sud-est
l'instrumentalisation de l'été par des
robespierre de l'écologie je veux dire
ça va être quelque chose de terrible si
c'est vrai c'est à dire que oui c'est
vrai il nous explique si par exemple on
a eu un été où il faisait frais
certains diraient tient d'été fera pas
non ne confondez pas météo et climat
mais là il a fait effectivement chaud
que d'habitude dérèglement climatique
ouais je dis juste ce calme ça va bien
se passer à quelle température elle avec
votre argent votre machine à laver je
dois bien avouer que c'est pas moi qui
l'avons largement tiré aux français si
c'était le cas mais ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'on essaie de faire avec son
attention désormais compris et dans la
réalité des services à ma taille il
suffit de navets à 30 degrés pourquoi tu
achètes pas une machine à laver
je ne veux pas acheter de machines parce
que le lavage à la main c'est beaucoup
plus efficace
le linge est plus propre qu'avec une
machine tu crois vraiment oui bien sûr
et pour les draps les couvertures tu
fais ça la main aussi oui tout à la main
quand l'hygiène c'est important
tu vois ce sont les plus même si je sais
qu'il va pas servir à tanger tout seul
si elle est apte à deux rendez-vous pas
samedi soir eh ben c'est pas une raison
pour se laisser le respectent souvent
toute la nuit j'ai réfléchi et je me
suis dit que aujourd'hui
vraiment droite au but si tu vas enquête
c'est toi moi ta vie ta vie ta confiance
jusqu'à présent str bas mais le pif
atteint 1000 sûrs ça y est c'est la
guerre faut y aller
clémence et david ce sont les deux seuls
dont au moins je sois certaine qu'ils
sont innocents un matin du journal de
mickey cherchons
à une blague ce week-end c'est qu'il y
en a alors là effectivement
qui me faisait c'est notre vie intime
on démarre avec alors un exemple oui un
chien très gros chiffre à
8,8 milliards total énergie le géant
pétrolier a réalisé un bénéfice donc de
18,8 milliards d'euros au premier
semestre 2009 un de ces trois fois plus
qu'à la même période l'an dernier des
résultats bien sûr en lien avec d'une
part l'activité économique qui fut bonne
et l'augmentation très forte de
l'essence à la pompe us
voilà merci beaucoup je vous embrasse
répit que par
mois aujourd'hui pour vous prouver à
quel point je vous fais confiance je
vous dévoile que je l' ai eu chez lui
son compte double
voilà pour vous dire vraiment ne vous
inquiétez pas je n'ai qu'une parole je
ne changerai pas ok et joue bretèche moi
c'est le courage c'est super je vous
montre la loyauté
c'est inacceptable d'avoir occulté ce
qui s'est passé dans ma vie depuis trois
mois et demi mais on est comme une
famille si vous l'avez dit à plusieurs
reprises et j'ai entendu toutes les
discours que vous avez tenus sur la
chaussée ou non mais j'ai besoin
de vous exprimer mais l'avocat ne vous a
pas à attaquer ils ont dit leur vérité
je vais te dire bamiyan oui mais je dois
je dire la mienne les ondes et avait
donc c'est justement au national mince
et souple et non mais c'est trop facile
et c'est moi mais je voulais vraiment
féliciter les prêtres parce que vous
êtes excellent
ce que je suis loyal quoi
[Musique]
j'me suis retrouvé d'autre est là
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis le dindon de la farce en
fait non
là les foules
arrêté j'ai envie de pleurer sur ma vie
je
fais la gueule mais j'ai gagné ici c'est
moi qui donne la parole donc je vais
vous dire ce que vous allez dire ou pas
dire même créé un droit de réponse j'ai
droit de démarrer mais c'est moi le chef
du plateau donc quand je suis
aujourd'hui je suis pas cramé oui mais
quand je dis quand je dis stop stop le w
adverbe issus de l'arabe algérien
parfois suivis de gros bien ou bien
voilà
wesh je me sens mais trahie d'une force
et je le dis c'est pas possible les deux
avec elle j'avais autant confiance à
coeur s'était promis tellement des
choses et ils m'ont tellement 10,3
deuxième attaque pas moi tu peux me
faire confiance faire confiance en fait
c'est eux les traîtres pas possible
c'est irréel là c'est le plus beau coup
de théâtre mais de toute l'aventuré quoi